[Musique]
cette semaine en quête la lumière sur
les troubles en appel trompeur ce qu'on
appelait les robes aux cols
[Musique]
l'information n'était pas prêt je ne
pouvais pas croire que ça se passait au
canada et une entrevue exclusive avec
celui que les conservateurs ont accusé
d'être pierre poutine
le responsable du scandale j'ai bondi
machette
j'étais complètement sous le choc dans
ce métier ta réputation si tout quand tu
la perds tu perds tout comme moussa et
dont le palais
[Musique]
bienvenue en quête le pseudonyme a pu
faire rire lorsqu'on a appris l'hiver
dernier qu'élections canada cherchaient
pierre poutine ce fut l'une des
premières pistes pour tenter de
découvrir qui était responsable de
milliers d'appels trompeur fait à l'aube
du dernier scrutin fédéral en 2011
des messages enregistrés pour confondre
les genres sur l'endroit où ils devaient
voter un jeune employé politique d'un
ministre est devenu le premier suspect
dans cette histoire il raconte ce soit
pour la première fois sa version des
faits enquête sur des traces de pierre
poutine
le matin de l'élection un message sur le
répondeur d'un fonds et l'homme au bout
du fil m'a dit c'est tout une voix de
femme
une fois enregistré qu il avait l'air
d'être une message officiel
c'est une voie avec une certaine
autorité
magique le message disait ceci est un
appel important d'élections canada un
problème c'est notre bureau de vote a
été déplacé
non c'était pas la place que je suppose
et d'aller l'information n'était pas
correct
[Musique]
c'était très étrange j'étais perplexe et
agacé
la première fois de ma vie je n'ai pas
voté at envois au juge lors de la
dernière élection fédérale
des milliers de canadiens ont reçu un
appel trompeur qui visait à supprimer
leur vote
ce qu'on croyait être une arnaque qui ne
concernait que google phone ontario
c'est andré maintenant à 234
circonscriptions sur 310 75 % des
circonscriptions du pays
c'est l'attaqué la plus sélect qui sont
les architectes de cette stratégie
importé des états unis welcome to make
up qui a été ciblée et pourquoi
hexion canada enquête depuis un an et
demi sur ses appels et personne est
encore accusé
on ne sait toujours pas qui se cache
derrière pierre poutine
[Applaudissements]
le 2 mai 2011 stephen harper fait élire
une majorité de députés conservateurs
[Applaudissements]
farinas
[Musique]
gouez dans le sud ouest de l'ontario les
conservateurs croyait pouvoir remporter
cette circonscription début de la
campagne mais elle est demeurée le
dernier bastion libéral la région
ce soir à stephen dégaine professeur à
l'université rentre du travail
il a reçu ce message étrange ça aurait
pu aider des élections canada sauf que
l'information n'était pas correct je ne
savais pas ce que j'avais déjà près de
7000 foyers de golf ont reçu l'appel
trompeur et une seule pour moi ça semble
essentiel en français le message semble
avoir été traduit par un mauvais
logiciel le message dirige les électeurs
au centre-ville de golf en pleine
construction à l'époque j'étais en
colère c'est un gros inconvénient plus
être trouver un stationnement
madame dean renonce à son droit
fondamental de voter sans vraiment mal
parce que pour la première fois de ma
vie je n'ai pas voté on voit où siègent
certains étaient vraiment fâché les
bureaux du candidat libéral france
valeriote est submergée d'appels plus
rock'n'roll
c'était le chaos plusieurs personnes
était la bonne savais même pas où va t
il se rend sur les lieux
champeau - certaines personnes sont
allées voter ailleurs d'autres ont
décidé de ne pas voter ou aux drogues
à quelques rues de là sous qu'un bon
reviennent son bureau de scrutin
elle a évidemment voté pour son mari le
candidat du parti vert dans walf sur son
répondeur le même message trompeur a pas
points
j'ai commencé à prendre conscience du
sérieux cette affaire assure ce soir
bref ça ressemble à une fraude mais
c'est une preuve fraude
l alerte élections canada sur ce qui est
en train de se passer
je ne pouvais pas croire que ça se
passait au canada le numéro de téléphone
sur l'afficheur dessous kembo à un
indicatif régional du québec le 4 5 076
077 4,6
l'enquète d'élections canada commence
dans les documents déposés au palais de
justice d'ottawa on apprend que le
numéro est enregistré au nom d'un
certain pierre poutine dit harper
[Musique]
nous suivons cette piste
nous apprenons que pierre poutine ehtp
cellulaire à guam
il a activé sous son pseudonyme et une
adresse rue séparatistes à joliette
il existe bien pierre poutine à l'ouest
20e c'est mon restaurant que j'ai parti
en 2007 parce que poutine en ontario ça
faisait s ici que pierre poutine a
choisi son pseudonyme font aussi le mur
j'ai une plaque mentionnant que je viens
de joliette
[Musique]
dix minutes après avoir activé son
cellulaire
pierre poutine ap chirac nine en alberta
c'est une entreprise qui offre un
système pour diffuser des messages
téléphoniques automatisés
ce qui n'a rien d'illégal en soi
l'entreprise collabore d'ailleurs à
lenquête d'élections canada dans les
documents le pdg de rak naïma meilleur
affirme que le soir du 30 avril
il a reçu l'appel d'un homme prénommé
pierre puisque cet homme dit être
recommandée par une personne du parti
conservateur du canada mais elle accepte
comme client rate nine un contrat
d'exclusivité avec le parti pierre
poutine devient le client 93 mais
échange d'identité dans sa fiche contact
chirac nine il devient pierre s.jones
résidents du 54 rue lajoie nord à
joliette
[Musique]
savez vous si 54 a déjà existé
à votre connaissance a jamais existé 54
ma factrice je cherche le 54 la joie
nord les 54 parfait qui suppose que de
gea monsieur jones qui aboutissent bon
samedi les jaunes
est ce que c'est un acquis important
jolie oui john jigal tabac c'est certain
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui les switchs
d'abord c'est pas la même chose mais à
ce moment alors c'était monsieur très
important il y avait une usine jaws
il existe encore une rue jones mais le
54 la joie nord n'existe pas
[Musique]
1er mai veille de l'élection
pierre poutine ou pierre jones bref
appelons le pierre seront dans deux
pharmacies golf et achètent des cartes
cadeaux visa et mastercard
il ouvre ensuite un compte paypal et
dépose 225 $ chirac n'a pour camoufler
l'adresse ip de son ordinateur
pierre passe par un paravent ethernet
aux péris de conquest un minuscule
village en saskatchewan
les serveurs se trouve à mclean en
virginie dans cet immeuble lorsque nous
nous y rendons en octobre l'entreprise a
déménagé
germanwings
elle possible pour les enquêteurs
d'élections canada de récupérer les
données
[Musique]
la veille de l'élection pierre rappelle
chirac nine cette fois entre 23h16 et
23h37
il télécharge le faux message
d'élections canada qui sera distribué à
compter de 10h le matin l'élection ils
programment ensuite une liste de six
mille sept cent trente sept numéros de
téléphone de google mais cette nuit-là
pierre fait une grosse erreur
à 2h10 du matin il ferme la cession du
client 93 ce traquenard
[Applaudissements]
trois minutes plus tard à partir du même
ordinateur
une autre session est ouverte celle du
cliente 45 le client numéro 45 est
enregistrée au 965 rue york
à goualich le bureau de campagne de
mighty borg
le candidat conservateur cette fois
pierre a oublié de camoufler son adresse
ip
mais qui était derrière l'ordinateur
cette nuit là et surtout combien y at-il
de pierre-paul isin à l'échelle du pays
après la pause le premier suspect à être
identifiés comme pierre poutine parle
pour la première fois le plus difficile
c'est de ne pas savoir à qui faire
confiance quand il n'y a plus personne
ce que tu croyais être tes amis tu es
vite
[Musique]
là où les appels trompeur on peut
changer le résultat d'élections c'est
dans le nord de l'ontario
la circonscription donnée piscine
témiscaming était libéral depuis les
années 20 à l'exception d'une courte
période dans les années 80 on est
toujours prêts à perdre ce ccc la
politique c'est ça c'est ça le jeu
l'ex-député libéral anthony rota a perdu
avec 18 voix de moins que le candidat
conservateur
quand tu perds parce que il ya des des
d'une question de froid ou d'une
question de torchage cette lettre un peu
amère
il est persuadé que les appels trompeur
ont contribué à sa défaite le matin de
l'élection on a commencé à voir des
appels à notre bureau de campagne des
gens qui se plaignait pizza j'ai eu un
appel d'élections canada d'aller voter à
une autre classe c'est arrivé à marica
nagasawa le matin du 2 mai on va voter à
l'école ici profite ici puis le message
m'a dit d'aller une autre endroit
j'ai trouvé c'est un petit peu bizarre
fringe ce n'est pas le même message
qu'adwords mais le stratagème est
semblable
delevoye était comme un petit peu puis
j'ai pensé c'est bizarre que j'ai eu
cette massage pire c'est la mauvaise
adresse qui la qualité c'est bizarre kim
ouvert
alors peggy wild craig a aussi reçu un
message mais quelques jours avant
l'élection
c'est le message disait qu'en raison du
taux de participation plus élevée que
prévu mon bureau de vote étaient
déplacés challenge je me suis demandé
comment il pouvait savoir qu'il y aurait
beaucoup d'électeurs puisque nous étions
à quelques jours de l'élection le saut
[Musique]
et à une soixantaine de kilomètres de
notre péché cannes feirense ce n'est pas
un message enregistré
il y a quelqu'un au bout du fil and i
know you go away matin environ 25
kilomètres sont vrais bureaux de scrutin
est à deux pas il en revient tout juste
cannes feirense a eu la vigilance de
conserver son relevé téléphonique numéro
élections canada ils ont dit que deux
jours plus tard ils étaient des bras
depuis les dernières élections élections
canada a retenu 1394 plainte précise des
canadiens qui ont signalé de faux
changement bureaux de scrutin mais aussi
d'autres tactiques déloyales des gens
qu'ils appliquent avec qui peut nous
appeler deux heures du matin à 10 heures
le soir
vous savez qu'on vous a pu et puis on se
demandait on n'a pas de jacky appelle
spéciale à ce temps là et puis nous on
appelait en toi
le bureau central du plan libéral on
leur disait garde
qu'est ce que vous faites vous appeler
tard le soir vous ai cité les gens qui
nous disaient car c'est pas nous jusqu'à
l'hiver dernier il en cas d'élections
canada se faisait plutôt discrètement en
février deux journalistes du cerezyme
commence à en révéler les grandes lignes
notamment les liens entre rac nine il
parti conservateur
le 23 février la chaîne sun news connue
pour ses liens avec les conservateurs
obtiennent tout un scout ce jour la
marque au sauna qui a travaillé pour la
campagne conservatrice de guelph regarde
ses news
il est alors à l'emploi de la député
yves adams
le journaliste dit on à une nouvelle de
dernière heure quelqu'un va être dans le
top 10 c'est sûr que c'est quelqu'un de
l'opposition quelque chose comme ça j'ai
bondi de ma chaise j'étais complètement
sous le choc
c'était complètement faux tapie ne l'ont
même jamais
quelques minutes plus tard la chaîne
obtient en exclusivité la déclaration du
parti conservateur qui promet que la
personne responsable sera puni et que le
parti n'a rien à voir dans le scandale
des appels trompeur et même espèce
j'ai commencé à me doutais de qui avait
coulé mon nom je sais qu'on ne peut pas
émettre communiqué sans avoir toutes les
autorisations
on a une bureaucratie n'ose y aura du
beau monde pour accrocher la couverture
se poursuit sur sun news
j'étais au téléphone avec un ami suis
dit c'est pas si pire les photos moi et
mon père avec le premier ministre
comme cela on voit au chantier avec un
fusil j'ai dit oublie sauf suis mort
howard longue date
c'est la première fois que mike hawthorn
a accordé une entrevue depuis les
événements il croit que ce sont les plus
hautes instances de son propre parti qui
ont coulé son nom à sun news un autre
facteur à sacrifier ma patronne a
d'abord refusé ma démission
puis quelqu'un du parti l'a appelé el
mahdi el hafi dalphond mais je suis
désolé mais je dois accepter ta
démission
même si le lendemain la chaîne nuance
ses propos il est trop tard pour lui
le plus difficile c'est de ne pas savoir
à qui faire confiance
non non on a beau tout poli qui truste
uni dont 9 danny boyle
quand il n'y a plus personne ce que tu
croyais être tes amis tu es vite dans ce
métier ta réputation c'est tout quand tu
la perds tu perds tout on use as et long
travail est fait pourtant le parti
conservateur avait un bon indice que
mâcon saunal n'était pas le suspect
idéal selon les documents dans le cadre
d'élections canada
les gens du golfe qui ont reçu l'appel
trompeur étaient tous sur une liste de
noms partisans conservateurs dans sims
la base de données des conservateurs
je me demande qu'est ce que j'avais fait
pour être sur la liste de jean kiffer le
diriger dans le mauvais sens
le parti a investi des ressources
importantes pour sonder les canadiens et
de façon encore plus intense à la proche
des élections ils font une personne dans
notre comté ont répondu au sondage avant
l'élection ma femme a répondu qu'elle ne
voterait pas conservateur on me
demandait une seule question si j'ai les
appuyer le parti conservateur dans la
prochaine élection
j'ai répondu non toutes ces informations
sont entrés dans la base de données
quand tu fais du porte-à-porte tu as une
feuille de sims l'adresse est un code à
barres qui permet de voir la fiche de
l'électeur est un des grands artisans ou
non non pour le second
le parti conservateur c'est exactement
qui fait quoi dans la base de données
sims tout est enregistré sur simone
prostate
si quelqu'un sur une liste de noms
partisans cet enregistrement
si quelqu'un sur une liste de partisans
7 enregistrée au nom importe ce que tu
fais c'est impossible à cacher
affaire fait disponibles toutes nos
informations à élections canada le parti
conservateur n'a rien faire serait
inapproprié 2012 le parti a fourni aux
enquêteurs d'élections canada
les noms de cinq travailleurs de la
campagne de bois qui ont accédé à sims
avec le même ordinateur que pierre
poutine
maiko son nom n'est pas sur cette liste
n'est jamais eu accès à sims de toute la
campagne le parti a confirmé à élections
canada que c'est un john prescott
directeur adjoint de la campagne qui a
téléchargé de sim's une liste
d'électeurs qui permettrait de cibler
les non partisan nous allons chercher un
job prescott partout à wells où son
entreprise de consultants en
informatique est toujours inscrit
ayew monsieur pasqua un membre de sa
famille finit par lui transmettre notre
demande d'entrevue ayew qui l'a décliné
après avoir passé plusieurs heures avec
nous au téléphone pour clamer son
innocence
entrée 5 e mais sa meilleure défense ce
témoignage du pdg de rak nine qui
connaît prescott et qui a dit aux
enquêteurs que pierre poutine n'avait
pas la même voix que lui au téléphone
[Musique]
marty burke le candidat conservateur n'a
pas voulu nous parler
pas plus que les 4 autres travailleurs
de la campagne de guen nommé par le
parti conservateur
rise of queens j'ai bien réfléchi à qui
pouvait avoir fait ça et finalement je
ne trouve personne dans l'équipe fin
d'année par sept jours après nos
premiers messages foot delory le porte
parole du parti conservateur nous a dit
qu'il n'avait aucune idée de qui avait
coulé le nom de michael sauna à sun news
il n'a pas voulu commenter nos autres
informations pour ne pas nuire à
élections canada dit il
si l'on cas d'élections canada d'envoi
il semble pointer vers quelques
travailleurs de la campagne
conservatrice
comment expliquer ce qui est arrivé
ailleurs au pays trois ans après
l'histoire de sun news l'avocat du parti
m'a appelé il voulait savoir quelle
compagnie avait travaillé à notre
campagne
peu après la mise au jour du scandale
une employée d'un centre d'appels de
thunder bay sort de l'ombre
annette desgagnés était à l'emploi de
responsive marketing group rmg qui a
obtenu des contrats pour la campagne
d'une centaine de candidats
conservateurs
et la signer une déclaration sous
serment que nous avons reconstitué
on était trente ou quarante personnes à
faire le même travail attendent de b
quelques jours avant les élections
le script que je devais lire au
téléphone a été modifié on disait aux
gens que leur bureau de scrutin avait
changé d'adressé
je me rappelle d'une femme à winnipeg
elle disait que la nouvelle adresse que
je lui donne est à plus d'une heure de
route de chez elle à l'aider gagner dit
avoir fait des appels d'un épais singh
témiscamingue
je me rappelle du comté de nipissing
timiskaming parce que j'avais de la
difficulté à dire témiscaming c'est le
comté contenir ôta a perdu par 18 voix
il dit avoir reçu un témoignage
semblable à celui d'anne et de gagner je
serai sa main j'ai eu un appel
j'étais chez nous on était c'était le
soir
une personne m'a appelé me dire que oui
en effet cette personne travaillait dans
un centre d'appels catinot et l'italie
faisait des appels entrants par anthony
rota ne veut pas répéter à la caméra le
nom de l'entreprise où ce témoin repenti
travaillait ils craignent poursuites
de son côté air mg soutient caennais
desgagnés fait erreur et que
l'entreprise n'a rien à voir dans le
scandale des appels trompeur la
déclaration d'anne est desgagnés a
néanmoins été déposée en cour fédérale
dans un recours de citoyens dont cannes
feirense et big one qui veulent faire
invalider les élections dans six
circonscriptions où les résultats
étaient serrés
il devrait y avoir une élection
partielle a longtemps couvé c'est du
jamais vu dans l'histoire du canada une
partie des frais d'avocats des
plaignants est prise en charge par le
conseil des canadiens
un groupe de pression aux idées
progressif je conclus que c'est juste
une campagne de salissage par le parti
qui a perdu les conservateurs
considèrent que ses citoyens ne servent
que de paravent leurs ennemis politiques
et qu'ils n'ont aucune preuve de ce
qu'ils avancent
hu a été pourquoi ont-ils élaboré un
document de 720 pages griffes pour
stopper la cause en cour
afp quand on veut la vérité on laisse
les choses procédé est dans le printemps
on ne les regarde pas la cause sera
entendue en décembre
ironiquement le seul qui a été condamnée
par élections canada et le crtc pour des
appels inapproprié c'est le député
libéral de golf la campagne de frank
valeriote de 2011 a fait des appels pour
dénoncer la position du candidat
conservateur sur l'avortement mais sans
préciser qui paient le message
il a admis son erreur mais il ne cesse
pour autant de dénoncer ce qui est selon
lui le vrai scandale ni tactique
antidémocratique
à la manière des républicains sont
importés des états unis au canada pour
empêcher les gens d'exercer leurs droits
démocratiques
à la pause stratagème importé des états
unis où tous les coups semblent permis
si vous n'avez pas payer une
contravention vous ne pouvez pas voter
c'est absolument faux ouah
[Musique]
dans quelques jours des américains ils
iront leur président on craint la barque
des stratèges politiques tenteront
d'induire certains citoyens en erreur
pour les empêcher de voter comme ça
s'est produit lors de la dernière
élection
nous poursuivons notre enquête
[Musique]
washington à quelques jours de
l'élection présidentielle
les lignes de 1 8 6 or vote ne
dérougissent pas c'est ici le comité des
avocats pour les libertés civiles qu'on
recueille les signalements
d'informations trompeuses donné aux
électeurs de partout aux états unis et
qu'on oriente les gens la directrice
tania klaus n'est pas surprise de ce qui
s'est passé au canada
bienvenue dans la politique américaine
c'est dommage que vous soyez confrontés
à ce problème
le cessna wallaby exporte ce n'est pas
ce que les états unis veulent exporter h
avec en cerise
ici il y à de multiples exemples de
tactique pour supprimer le vote comme au
lieu d'user si vous n'avez pas payer une
contravention vous ne pouvez pas voter
d'allez c'est absolument faux bond au
tennessee
et si la pension alimentaire n'est pas
payée pas le droit de vote et
chronophage
oui ce concert un autre message trompeur
vous ne pouvez pas voter à la
présidentielle
vous avez déjà voté dans n'importe quel
autre élection cette année et en indiana
vous avez été un électeur tellement si
du que cette fois-ci vous pouvez voter
par téléphone
c'est faux et une tactique classique aux
états unis observé en noyaux et en
virginie
micmacs dire que les démocrates soit le
mercredi et les républicaine mardi mme l
ici le jour de l'élection est toujours
un martine aubry refusé au rayon des
tactiques déloyales à la new haven
ancien stratège embauché par les
républicains c'est quoi il parle il a
fait de la prison pour son rôle dans une
élection au new hampshire en 2002
on a bloqué les lignes téléphoniques et
démocrates le jour de l'élection
ça fait scandale en 2008 il a écrit un
livre pour dénoncer ce qui dans
l'establishment du parti républicain lui
avait passé la commande
il y confesse tous les coups bas qui l'a
fait il me faut on a fait des appels le
jour du super bowl en se faisant passer
pour notre opposant on ciblait les gens
qui n'étaient pas des supporteurs de
notre candidat on savait qu'il ne serait
pas content et blâmerait notre
adversaire il ya aussi la tactique de
l'homme noir fâché on appelait des
électeurs blancs et on leur parlait avec
un accent afro-américains très prononcé
pour les encourager à voter pour notre
adversaire
en réalité on voulait leur faire peur
pour qu'ils décident de ne pas voter
démocrate à cause de cet appel
et plusieurs des tactiques recensé cible
les minorités
le plus souvent les afro-américains guy
la dernière enseigne le droit à
l'université de bâle témoin
c'est une spécialiste des tactiques de
suppression de vote et d'intimidation
des électeurs
chongqing des afro américains évoquent
surtout pour les démocrates
par exemple en 2008 ils ont voté à 90 %
pour obama et le pape malickou recettes
et 1 et et on s'attend la même chose
cette année et huff est probable qu'ils
avaient donc c'est en tant pour les
républicains d'utiliser des tactiques
trompeuses pour réduire cet avantage
ils ont certainement fait par le passé
johnny depp
les républicains sont plus à l'aise avec
les électeurs blancs ils ne sont pas à
l'aise avec les minorités figure
s'ils ne peuvent pas communiquer avec
elle s'ils n'ont rien à leur dire que
peuvent-ils faire pour influencer le
vote
la réponse a été en supprimant leur vote
ce prof
[Musique]
c'est ici à ben témoin que l'un des
pires scandales de suppression vote a eu
lieu en 2010
lors de la course au poste de gouverneur
du maryland
la campagne du candidat républicain a
envoyé un message trompeur dans 112
mille foyers dans les quartiers à plus
forte majorité noire bien avant la
fermeture des bureaux de scrutin
on faisait croire que le candidat
démocrate avait déjà gagné un procès
retentissant eut lieu le cerveau de
l'opération a été condamné à la prison
scène qui a prêté sa voix pour le
message a profité l'immunité en échange
de son témoignage
ils ont accepté de nous parler des
rousses au monde est la prouesse il y a
quelqu'un qui a pris la décision d'un
professeur et ce n'était pas noir taos
fox neo est sonné comme dubaï
encore aujourd'hui il persiste à dire
que c'était une opération de psychologie
inversée ou spécifiques et une idée
était que si vous étiez un partisan du
candidat républicain des massages et que
vous entendez ce message à 1h45 de la
fermeture des bureaux de vote le boring
pioche
cela vous pousserez à aller voter le
plus rapidement possible de deux
mécanismes
ça ne se peut pas passer non c'est
ridicule est-ce vous qui avez pensé à
cette stratégie de stratégie c'était la
stratégie du stratège johnson alors ils
se pressent pas visé personnellement
c'est ça la politique
rogers le jury ne les a pas crues du
relief en scène a été condamné à deux
mois de prison
c'était comme en prison j'ai je ne
reviendrai pas c'était très humiliant et
une amende d'un million de dollars
est-ce que vous avez un million de
dollars ja oui mais je me donnerais pas
l'état du maryland
il est présentement en appel la décision
la tromperie des électeurs est très
difficile à prouver
mais dans le cas du maryland il existait
des éléments de preuve démontrant qu'il
s'agissait d'une opération suppression
possible maintenant
le maryland est l'un des rares états qui
a des lois spécifiques qui criminalise
les tactiques visant à supprimer le vote
c'est exactement ce qu'on aimerait voir
se produire dans d'autres états ils ne
se créent à colmar pour dissuader ceux
qui seraient tentés par ces pratiques
son organisme milite pour que les
pratiques trompeuses soit criminalisé
partout aux états unis au départ and
dreams était bien prêt nir sa langue
pour protéger le parti jusqu'à ce que
lev pia et débarque
oui je sais qu'il faut toujours un bouc
émissaire aux corses à ce but bien sûr
il doit y en avoir un habituellement
c'est la personne la moins importante
je n'étais qu'un fournisseur de services
soa noir
jamais il n'aurait imaginé faire un jour
de la prison une expérience qui l'a pris
avec philosophie
après dix ans avec les républicains
trois mois avec denain criminelle
s'était pas la fin du monde
après la pause l'enquète d'élections
canada piétine
à quand des réponses de son poste ils
enquêtent depuis 17 mois
ils ont dépensé 250 mille dollars et
quels sont les résultats
c'est frustrant que trois collègues
[Musique]
avant le déluge de plaintes sur les
appels trompeur et l'élection de 2011
élections canada avait été alertée à au
moins deux reprises sur des tactiques
semblables
cette fois la pression est plus forte et
lucide et la faire dans plus de 200
salles conscription donne océan à
l'autre
[Musique]
lorsqu'éclate le scandale en février
2012 les manifestations ont lieu dans 17
villes du pays
on ne sait toujours pas qui est pierre
poutine mais si le passé est garant de
l'avenir
on ne le saura peut-être jamais en 2008
le parti vert c'était plein d'appels
trompeur dans la circonscription
qu'occupe aujourd'hui il a bêtement
élections canada n'a pas résolu la faire
en 2009 lors d'une élection partielle
dans kamouraska montmagny l'islet
rivière du loup le bloc québécois a
dénoncé des appels qui visait à irriter
ses partisans dès 4h30 le matin les gens
se réveiller ce message enregistré
parfois aussi c'était la répétition
acheté 15 minutes pendant une heure une
heure trente que les gens recevaient ce
téléphone là l'artisan d'aller voter et
de ne pas oublier d'aller voter pour
leur candidate du bloc québécois et
quitte il advenu de ces plaintes faites
par le bloc québécois à la police et à
élections canada rien autant la sûreté
du québec directeur des élections ne
peut plus rien prouvé alors c'est tombé
dans l'oubli au québec lors de
l'élection fédérale de 2011 le parti
libéral dit avoir reçu des plaintes dans
neuf circonscriptions
ça s'est produit effectivement la
circonscription ça fait aucun doute
parce que c'est c'est plus qu'une
personne qui nous a relaté des
événements c'est précisément cet air pur
donner un avantage au parti conservateur
mais qui est responsable
j'espère que l'en tête d'élections
canada aussi également l'enquêté de la
grc va pouvoir nous
nous éclairer élections canada a demandé
l'aide de la grc mais refuse de
commenter quoi que ce soit dans cette
affaire
diamond qui enquête depuis 17 mois
ils ont dépensé 250 mille dollars et
quels sont les résultats
c'est frustrant
my concernant est furieux d'avoir été
nommés dans les documents dans le cadre
d'élections canada
mais il a refusé de rencontrer les
enquêteurs sur les conseils de son
ancien avocat du prix c'est avant tout
les preuves démontrent que ce n'est pas
moi je veux des excuses jean-pierre king
lui qui a été directeur général des
élections pendant 17 ans ne crois pas
que l'organisme doivent s'excuser
il a quand même été fort impressionnés
par le témoignage de michael sont à même
si la franchise
ça nous aide énormément à comprendre ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur des partis
politiques
pour lui ce qui s'est passé à l'élection
de 2011 est sans précédent
c'est la facture et cette attaque doit
être sanctionné on ne tripote pas le
système électoral canadien avec
limpidité
non cela doit-on savoir qui a posé le
geste
on doit aussi savoir est-ce qu des
autorisations est ce que les
autorisations direct parce qu les
autorisations que j'appelais les
autorisations sourde
en d'autres mots fais ce que tu dois
faire je ne veux pas savoir sûr que tu
fais jean-pierre qingli est inquiet de
la direction que semble prendre le monde
politique depuis quelques années j'ai
constaté ce que j'appellerais un
durcissement de ton un approfondissement
des convictions
[Musique]
si on a raison tous les moyens sont bons
tous les moyens sont bons parce qu'on
estime avoir quelque chose plus
outrageant l'actuel directeur général
des élections marc mayrand a promis un
rapport en mars 2013 sur les appels
trompeur s'il faut faire un rapport
selon laquelle on ne sait pas qui ça va
lui est d'aller encore on ne sera pas
satisfait c'est aussi ce que pensent les
citoyens qui ont reçu des appels
trompeur et qui sont inquiètes
si on dit rien il veut pas c'est que
c'est correct puis on peut assez encore
atteinte il est vital au scandale les
appels trompeur robot cros cadeau c'est
que les gens sont plus attentifs aux
processus démocratiques chance je crois
qu'il y avait n'est pas qu'au 19e où on
offrait de la bière aux hommes pour
qu'ils votent pour tel ou tel candidat
je trouve que les moyens actuels sont
plus insidieux
si on a su que la bière
[Musique]
côté beauté
si vous voulez nous contacter consultez
notre site internet à l'adresse suivante
voulez faire vos commentaires et aux
suggestions et revoir nos reportages
pour connaître notre démarche
journalistique que je vous invite à
consulter mon blogue juillet prendre
note qu'en quête et rediffusée le
dimanche à 18h sur deux réseaux
d'information
[Applaudissements]
la semaine prochaine enquête nous fonds
marins subissent l'équivalent de la
coupe à blanc le canada laisse tomber
ses océans aux coupes dans les apports
coupes dans les budgets en coupe même
dans les lois
sunstar programme depuis l'arrivée du
gouvernement après tout s'est écroulé
d'espèce c'est pas grave le pétrole
c'est payant j'ai beaucoup plus payant
sans attendre beaucoup plus dans les
coffres du gouvernement
merci d'avoir été là bonsoir la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]